should you get an iPhone 15 Pro Max or
save
$300 and get a 15 plus well I'm going to
tell you guys every single difference
skipping the specs but focusing on real
world differences and this year the
results are a lot different than last
year and I think you guys are going to
be surprised now I mentioned that price
difference there and you have a
difference of ram 256 versus
128 now most people don't need 256 so
that's a 300 difference and I was
surprised that the memory speed is not
much slower even though it is half the
capacity now as far as the comfort in
hand last year I loved the 14 plus
because it was so much lighter but this
year the difference is very minimal and
with that the 15 Pro Max is actually
slightly narrower and slightly shorter
than the 15 plus and because of the new
curved edges on the front and the back
both phones feel very comfortable and
it's hard to tell that the 15 Pro Max is
slightly thicker now we definitely have
a difference in camera bums the 15 Pro
Maxes sticks out quite a bit more so if
you don't like Wobble the 15 plus is a
little bit better in that way and one
difference this year is that the new
titanium no longer feels a lot more
premium in the hand compared to the
aluminum they actually feel almost
identical now of course most people are
going to be using a case so no matter
which one you buy you should definitely
get a reliable case like these from our
sponsor casify who make the most
protective cases out there like their
impact case bounce case and their brand
new Ultra bounce and impact ring stand
cases their bestselling impact case is
super slim and stylish offering drop
protection of up to four times the
military standard with their twister
ecoshock in lining which you can now
also get in the new ringstand variant
with a built-in kickstand so you can
prop it up for or watching videos if you
want more protection the bounce case has
up to six times military drop protection
being 16% Slimmer than before and their
newest Ultra bounce case takes it up to
10x the military standard with their
revolutionary Ultra bounce corners and
six layers of protection including the
integrated camera lens cover to give you
incredible draw protection all of them
are made out of 65% recycled and
plant-based materials featuring mag
saafe and being available in a ton of
customizable prints like this one which
is my personal favorite because of the
cool tear down design so check out one
of kfi's new iPhone 15 cases by going to
casey.com
maxt and save 15% off your order today
now the next Real World difference is
the action button on the 15 plus you
have that classic silent switch which is
really nice but having this action
button you can do a ton of things I have
mine set to open up the camera app and
that is very convenient but you can also
use it for silent mode focus camera
flashlight voice memos and of course
shortcuts so you can customize this to
whatever you want and how much does that
matter in the real world well I think it
is nice compared to just that silent
rocker but I don't think it's something
that will make you get the pro Max
instead of the plus now as far as
speakers the 15 Pro Max is so impressive
it got louder this year the sound
quality is better and typically the
regular iPhone including the 14 plus
sounded worse than the pro variant but
this year I was shocked go ahead and
take a listen for
[Music]
yourself the 15 plus either sounds
identical or very close to the pro MX
Max and that is awesome the apple is
using really great speakers on both so
you don't really get a downside now the
next thing I want to talk about is
battery life I was also impressed with
the battery life of the 15 Pro Max it
actually got better even though they
didn't quote it getting better but even
though the 15 Pro Max has a larger
battery the battery life seems to be
better on the 15 plus now I didn't do a
crazy in-depth test like Mister who's
the boss did but in his comparison the
15 plus is the best phone he has ever
tested and in the real world you can
tell now I was not expecting this
because the a17 pro is a 3 nanm compared
to the a16 which is a mix of 4 nanm and
5 nanom so should be less efficient
right well the A7 Pro actually uses up
to 14 watts of power whereas the a16
runs at roughly 10 to 11 so that's up to
40% more power when the phones needs to
use high performance that is crazy and
that results in some great battery life
now thankfully as far as 5G speeds the
15 plus this year has the same x70 as
the pro Max which is awesome and that
actually saves battery life which is
helping it out as well and the speeds
compared to the 14 lineup are quite a
bit faster both outdoors and indoors and
that is really nice to know that this
year you're not going to be sacrificing
speed and reception now as far as
charging speed the 15 Pro Max actually
goes up to 27 watts compared to 25 and
it takes an hour and 25 minutes for a
full charge compared to an hour and 45
minutes and that's just a difference of
how much power it accepts throughout the
whole charging cycle so it's a little
bit quicker now another crazy thing this
year is that Apple brought the dynamic
Island to the 15 plus where last year it
still had add that old Notch and with
that we did not expect it to get the
super bright xdr display that can hit up
to 2,000 nits so outdoor brightness is
now the same you get PR level brightness
same thing for watching HDR video uh the
brightness and quality is identical
which is so nice so as far as the
screens you're not missing out for the
most part but there are a couple
stipulations first off you do not get
the always on display like get on the 15
Pro Max that is Apple just limiting it
and this is nice because you can have
widgets you can see your data it is
something that I really enjoy and with
that you do not get promotion so you get
60 HZ compared to up to 120 so it's
definitely noticeable that the pro Max
is smoother and if you have a tablet or
you had an older phone that had
promotion you will notice the 60 HZ
being a little bit stuttery but if you
have an experience a promotion before
you won't know the difference and it's
going to be just fine so I wouldn't make
that a huge kind of uh deal if you're
trying to decide now another difference
that we have is the ram last year it was
the same but this year the pro Max has
bumped up to 8 gigs compared to the same
6 gigs on the plus model now how much of
a difference does that make in the real
world and to be honest I could not tell
both of them did a great job with
applications and I think just 6 gigs is
a pretty good middle ground where a
couple years ago 4 gigs you could see a
difference now as far as performance
looking at geekbench 6 in the single
core we had an 11% difference and in
multicore we had a 12% difference to be
honest with you guys that does not
really matter the a16 bionic is still a
great chip and it's going to be
supported for another 5 years now in
terms of graphics performance here we
had a difference of
18% and that is more noticeable but it's
still not a massive difference years ago
we' have a much bigger difference now
one thing I have to point out is the new
a17 Pro supports Ray tracing now which
gives you more realistic Reflections and
shadows and it also has metal effects
upscaling which makes it easier on the
actual chip to get better graphics with
lower draws on the GPU now unfortunately
this is brand new we are waiting for
games to come out to support this and
with that apple is bringing some console
level games to the iPhone 15 Pro phones
only so you're going to have to have the
A7 Pro so if you really enjoy gaming
that's something that I would think
about now there is one thing that has
dominated the headlines with this launch
that has to be overheating and
throttling people keep talking about the
15 Pro Maxes 15 Pro is getting super hot
so did I notice this between the two
phones and I will say yes I did I did
notice that the 15 Pro Max feels hotter
in the hand when you are using it and
that because the new titanium is not a
great conductor of heat but aluminum is
a great one now using these dayto day I
don't think that's a massive difference
even though when you're charging it gets
hotter it feels hotter especially in
certain apps that I think still need
some optimization but I did a 20-minute
throttling Extreme Gaming stress test
and what is interesting is that both
phones dimed down to the same brightness
um when I was running it so the plus
didn't really get any better in that
regard now right at the end of the test
the max had noticeably more heat buildup
it hit 47° C compared to 44 celsi and on
the back side you can actually see the
outline of the A7 Pro chip and even a
bit of the charging coils now if we look
at the results from this test the peak
frame rate is roughly 40% higher on the
pro Max with the A7 Pro chip but this
phone with a titanium throttles so
quickly that by the end of loop one the
overall performance difference is only
18% and then after the whole test was
done when they both heated up the
performance difference was 19% so if
you're worried about the performance is
getting super slow on a pro Max so
you're thinking about getting the plus
well it ends up being the same once both
of them are heated up now the crazy
difference though is that the 15 plus
cooled off very quickly and the screen
went to full brightness after about 30
seconds while on the pro Max it took 2
minutes or longer showing just how good
aluminum is um at being able to cool off
quickly and dissipate heat so if this is
something that you're really worrying
about or you want to avoid that is is
definitely a plus for the cheaper 15
plus and now it is time to talk about
photo quality because this year we have
some big differences the 15 plus went up
to 48 megapixels and it got some extra
features and that is amazing because
that makes it a way better phone than
the 14 plus but the pro Max now has that
5x lens and believe it or not there's
actually benefits uh and negatives with
both phones so I have a bunch of
pictures here to show you guys and
starting out with a 48 megapixel picture
they look pretty much identical which is
awesome now looking at the selfie
cameras here they actually have the same
exact hardware and both have Smart H5 so
they practically look the same now
here's another regular photo it is 48
megapixel it looks great at Sunset and
crapping in I would say that the 15 plus
looks slightly better and in this shot
right here if I punch in and I look once
again the 15 plus has slightly more
detail now it actually has a newer
sensor than the one in the 15 Pro Max
which is actually reused from last year
so that could be it and now let's talk
about the zoom quality because the 15
plus does not have a dedicated zoom lens
this shot you guys already saw but I
want you guys see the maximum Zoom you
could do which is 25 on the pro Max and
10 on the plus even here you see the
quality difference and then if I crop in
that is a huge difference here the same
thing in this shot having the ability to
zoom in much more is awesome and the
quality looks better too even though
you're zoomed in more and based off this
sign you guys could see I can clearly
read everything on the pro Max whereas
the plus it's all garbled up and messed
up so if you find yourself zooming in
often the pro Max is much better now
looking at some portrait shots this 1X
looks very similar but on the pro Max
you can see where have a little bit
better dynamic range now thankfully both
of them can take 2x shots now which was
a issue with the 14 plus and they look
so dang close they look identical but
the pro Max now has that 5x telephoto
lens and that allows you to get this
beautiful bokeh and remove some of the
background compared to the plus which 2x
is the maximum you can get still looks
good but it is not the same here's
another shot with the sun in the
background I'm getting less um issues
with flaring and the image just looks
really good with that 5x portrait and
the same thing here with this bunny shot
I framed it the same but having that
extra blur looks really nice in certain
cases now both Ultra wide lenses have
the same 12 megapixels but the 15 Pro
Maxis has autofocus so here I could get
really close to that flower compared to
the plus that is the closest I can get
of course you can crop but then the the
quality goes down quite a bit and then
here we have a regular ultrawide shot
and even looking like this without
cropping in the Pro Max looks a little
bit more detailed but then if we look at
the center you definitely notice that
detail and then on the edges the
difference is massive so not only do you
have the macro mode the overall quality
of the lens is better on the pro Max now
there is one issue with the pro Max that
the plus thankfully doesn't have even
though it now shoots 48 megapixels you
guys could see here that the pro Max is
blurred and that is because the minimal
focusing distance is not very good with
this 48 megapixel uh camera whereas a
plus it looks great and because of this
if you're shooting a document or a
closeup box right here the pro Max just
doesn't do a good job where the plus
looks awesome and this is actually how
close I can get so you guys can see that
difference now I talked about this issue
last year when Apple launched this 48
megapixel and the pro phones and you can
get around that by using the macro mode
but then the quality goes down or by
shooting a wide photo and then cropping
in the quality also goes down and it's
nice to know that you don't have that
issue with the plus so if you shoot a
lot of documents um things that need
close distance that is really nice now
going into night mode I thought that the
plus would get noticeably worse photos
but the shots look pretty much the same
and only in the most extreme lighting
the 15 Pro Max's slightly larger sensor
can pick up a little bit more light and
that helps it out now one area where the
regular iPhones always struggled is low
light portraits so here you guys could
see that the pro Max looks so much
better and that's because it has that
lighter sensor and that allows it to
enable night mode with portrait at the
same time and that makes the shots look
much better if you like taking low light
portraits so bringing us back to the the
original question should you get the 15
Pro Max or should you save
$300 and get the 15 plus well last year
I said do not buy the 14 plus there was
a massive difference there but this year
it is very interesting because Apple
added enough to this phone while keeping
the base price the same that I would say
for a lot of people this is an excellent
buy it has great battery life you have
the dynamic island in the bright display
you have a much better camera before and
of course you have USB type-c which
while it's not as fast as the pro Maxes
most people aren't using it to transfer
data anyway so if you're on the fence
and you don't need some of the extra
luxuries of the pro Max or that zoom
lens I would say get the plus you will
not be disappointed but if you're going
to keep your phone for a very long time
you have the money to spend this year
the pro Max it's a lot lighter it's more
comfortable so you're not um missing out
on that benefit of the plus series you
can spend the extra money but I was just
very impressed with the plus this year
and I think it is a great buy you guys
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments section below go ahead and
check out case toies cases as well click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those videos right over there
this has been Max and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one